so it's september of 2009 i'm 30 years
old i just started my own insurance
company and i get sued within 30 days
by a 400 billion dollar company and this
company that suits me the company that i
left
they had their lawyers start recruiting
others having meetings with folks that
were working with me to give some dirt
to them and there was this meeting in
one of our guys without telling me goes
to this meeting
there's 17 other people there the
lawyers are asking questions everybody's
saying what they're saying and this guy
comes to my office
that night he says patrick there was a
meeting today you didn't know about
here's what the lawyers have been doing
i got the recording of the entire
conversation of what everybody said
about you and i'm giving this to you to
show you how loyal i am to you anyways
i'll tell you in a minute what i do with
that recording and why this message has
to do with winning at the highest level
by the way if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel so let me get right into
it so
he comes to me and he says here's what's
going on now here's what's going on at
that time like company wise i had been
with the company for seven and a half
years i love the company i never wanted
to leave the company i wanted to be the
ceo of the company i held meetings i met
with the ceos i met with every c suite i
met with their i flew out to atlanta i
talked to entire lawyer legal everybo i
had a meeting with everybody i could
they came they met with me i met with
them at hotels at midnight to let them
know i don't want to leave i'm not a
coward i have those meetings with people
then i took my pastor with me to pebble
beach i said i want you to meet these
people they're good people but i want to
know what i need to do next for the rest
of my life it took me 12 months to make
my decision
until i finally made my decision to
leave and at that point everybody knew
where pat stood there was a meeting that
took place i think in diamond bar and
everybody's in the room and it was the
biggest players who were all about to
leave they were upset with the company
and i sat there and i said guys
if you're all here i'm telling you what
i'm doing next here's where i'm at
everybody knew
i had a meeting with one of their
leaders he was a main leader at the time
in hawaii and we're sitting there and i
said i want to ask you some questions
and i want you to answer and i want you
to look him in my eyes
he said the sun is on my face i said
let's switch seats so we switch seats
i said i get a feeling you're just
you know milking the cash that you're
making here but you don't love this
business and i get a feeling you don't
have a vision where you want to take
this next and i want to have this
conversation with you where's this
company going to next an hour later
there's a bunch of people sitting around
the pool trying to see what this meeting
is going to be like and eventually after
asking enough questions said yeah i
really don't know where we're taking
this company next i said i can't do that
because i know exactly where i'm going
and then boom next thing you know six
months later i started my own insurance
company anyways
these guys sue me 400 billion dollar
company
no hard feelings they're supposed to sue
me because i was a player who left and i
was one of the top guys there and i'm
starting i'm a threat they're supposed
to do that trade secrets all these
things that they're gonna do eventually
we settled no issues eight months later
didn't take clients didn't take anything
we started our own business went our
separate ways we haven't had any issues
for
13 years so
but this guy shows up to my office and
he says pat
what everybody said in that meeting is
in this recording you should hear what
they said about you
you should hear what this lawyer asked
about you
and he hands it to me and i look at it
i'm like
boom
throw in the trash right in front of him
he said how could you do that i said
what do you mean he said you don't want
to know what people said about you i
said zero
he says why not i said why do i want to
know what they said about me
i said see the way i make a decision i
take a long time before i say i'm out
but when i'm out i'm out i'm not playing
around
and i don't i value my time a lot and i
value a lot
meaning if you don't see value in having
a friendship with me or business
relationship with me i'm not a beggar
i'm not in the convincing business
you're either in
or you're either out i don't play the
lukewarm game we're either going to take
over the world together we're not and by
the way i don't think i'm the last
person in the world that's going to do
something big the market's got 8 billion
people 330 million people in america
there's plenty of market but this is
what i'm going to be doing here's where
i'm going you want to do something let's
go if you're somebody that's at a season
of your life that you don't want to
light it up you just want to kind of be
relaxing kicking back not giving your
best it's not the season where i'm in
i'm going to go play ball
pat there's no way you're not going to
listen to this i'm not going to listen
to it i'm telling you i'm not going to
listen to enough i never once listened
to it by the way
when i left
i got stacks of letters that people send
me i never open them
i don't want to read them
i don't nothing i'm gone you know so i'm
like oh let me check what this former
employee is doing on insta stories or
facebook or snapchat or whatever it is i
don't follow any of it i wish everybody
the best i'm a capitalist as a
capitalist i think the market's massive
and i'm very confident of my abilities
on what i'm going to be doing if i don't
treat somebody right or if i don't do
something right strategy wise the
market's going to hurt me and it's my
fault i totally get it i'm a big boy i
get it but i don't want to constantly
live that i'm moving on and by the way
you know what's crazy
if people do it the right way and you
kind of you know you're going through
the real way you're able to sit down
kneecap to kneecap have conversations
like that i salute you
years later those people the person that
i had a conversation with hawaii called
me
and hey i apologize i said yeah dude
we're over it let's just move on
and i had those conversations over and
over and over again but the moral of the
story to you is this
um
listen
hot or cold you want to do it let's go
you don't want to do it let's not go
lukewarm i'm not doing it
i'm patient until you fully in but if
you're in let's go some of you guys
uh dwell too much on the past some of
you follow your exes way too much
you're not together no more stop
following your ex on
insta stories and snap create a fake
profile to see what they do stop doing
that
you're not together move on something
happens next six 12 24 months maybe it
does
many of these guys that i didn't do
business with one of the people that was
in there that said a lot of bad things
about me according to what this guy that
came and told me about
that person is not working with me we
saw each other in cancun she ran up to
me hugged me we had the best
conversation it was emotional both of us
because she herself said pat listen i
was delusional we had some challenges at
that time i was being fed a lot of
different things but you never once
mistreated me my husband or my family
i'm so glad we're in business today i
said awesome
awesome if i'm good market's going to
favor if i'm not it's not going to favor
me then i deserve it right but message
to you is this
if you're in
go in
if you're working with people that are
in and you're in the face of your life
that you want to do something big go all
in lukewarm hasn't served anybody
there's not a single person that's
favored or one in business from being
lukewarm anyways
if you got some value out of this
lukewarm message that i gave you about
the lawsuit i experienced in 2009 give
it a thumbs up and subscribe there's a
video out there we made a year and a
half ago two years ago titled
how to reach your full potential if
you've never watched it click over here
to watch it take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]